oh my God
excuse me
[Music]
hello
little girl
how dare you enter the glitches laugh
the internet the audacity neon mitigated
God you've caught
now get ready
Mr Grinch
my name is Cindy Lou Who you see even
now the carer is welling up inside you
I'm not scared and Irish to be expected
in the face of Pure Evil
[Applause]
I don't think so
don't another unmistakable significance
no you're dude
[Applause]
run for your life before I kill again
I'm a psycho
um maybe you need a timeout
kids today
so desensitized by moving and television
what do you want
[Music]
of course they are
that's what it's all about isn't it
that's what it's always been about
you want to know what happens to your
gifts
they all come to me
in your garbage you see what I'm saying
in your garbage
I could hang myself with all the bad
Christmas neckties I found at the top
the Everest never ends I want golf clubs
I want diamonds I want a pony so I can
ride it twice get bored and tell it to
make glue look I don't want to make
waves but this whole Christmas season is
still stupid stupid
there is however
one
teeny tidy Christmas tradition
I find
quite meaningful
now Parker up and kisses
[Music]
wow somebody's fabulous
[Music]
yeah
let's go excuse me Old Timer
reminder well
that's some good stuff
foreign
[Music]
the tall and the small were singing
without any Presence at all
[Music]
he hadn't stopped Christmas from coming
just the same foreign
the Grinch with his Grinch feet ice cold
in the snow stood puzzling and puzzling
how could it be sure
it came without ribbons
came without eggs
game without packages boxes of bags
and he puzzled and puzzled till his
Puzzler was sore
then the Grinch thought of something
he hadn't before
Maybe
Christmas he thought
come from a store
maybe Christmas
perhaps
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nice
[Applause]
help me
I'm
feeling
and what happened then
well in Whoville they say the inches
small heart
grew three sizes
that day
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]